anbringen und zwar habe ich vor allem in
der letzten Woche das Gefühl bekommen
dass deutsche Medien vor allem eines
eint und das ist ihre
freiheitsverachtung es klingt sehr
schlimm aber jemand sagt die
coronazahlen steigen kann man irgendwie
die Beitrage zählen also Beiträge in
Zeitungen und auch sonst von
Verfassungsrechtlern oder Soziologen
aber eben auch Redaktoren in
verschiedenen Zeitungen wieder FAZ oder
süddeutschen oder Zeit die irgendwie dem
Individuum die Schuld quasi in allem
geben also das Ende des Zeitalters das
Individuums heranschreiben dass ich muss
quasi in das Kollektiv zurücktreten fürs
Allgemeinwohl das nimmt mir doch
einigermaßen Wunder bzw auch wieder ein
bisschen mit weil die Deutschen sind ja
eigentlich schon ein sehr
kollektivistisch tickendes Volk ich
frage mich nur wie das jemals ändern
soll weil wenn irgendwie die die den
meinungsdiskurs bestimmen die dem
Einzelnen die Eigenverantwortung
absprechen dann kann sie das ja auch nie
ändern aber Freiheit beginnt ja nun mal
beim Einzelnen und nicht bei der Gruppe
also eine Gesellschaft besteht auch nur
Individuen weil das Individuum denenität
ist das handelt das frei ist und das
denkt also insofern es gibt keinen
kollektiven Gedanken es gibt kein
heutiges Tschechien und die wird mir
sehr wünschen dass dieses Passion des
innovialismus am Ende findet das sind
ganz gutes Thema weil ich auch
gestolpert bin diese Woche über den Chef
des weltärztenverbandes Frank uhligmann
gomery und dessen Schlagwort vom
freiheitsgesäusel das fand ich das wäre
für mich eigentlich das Unwort des
Jahres das klingt irgendwie so als ob
Freiheit so eine lästige Geschichte ist
muss doch jeder einsehen es ist jetzt
ein bisschen intern lassen weil das
jetzt mal mit der Freiheit und beim
nächsten dann können wir es auch wieder
machen so ähnlich höre ich das manchmal
von Fridays for future weil die
Dringlichkeit des Klimaschutzes ist ja
unwidersprochen also jetzt gehört auch
mit eurem demokratischen Mechanismen das
dauert alles zu lange wir müssen jetzt
erstmal handeln und wenn man erstmal so
rangeht dass man sagt die
Grundfesten dieser freiheitlichen
Ordnung sind eigentlich je nach Anlass
verhandelbar und wenn es jetzt gerade
nicht passt dann nächste Woche wieder
mal gucken ob es dann besser ist das ist
so eine gesandt seltsame Grundhaltung um
jetzt nicht zu schwer zu werden
böckenförder hat ja mal gesagt der
ehemalige Verfassungsrichter wir leben
von Grundlagen in dieser Ordnung die wir
selbst nicht schaffen können da ist
natürlich was dran und diese Wurstigkeit
wie man mit den Grundrechten umgeht die
macht mir auch durchaus Sorgen weil am
Ende sich möglicherweise sogar
Mehrheiten dafür finden dass man sagt ja
sehen wir alle Notlage können wir jetzt
ja nächste Woche reden wir wieder drüber
finde ich schwierig ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt warum wir gerade auch im
Osten Deutschlands eine große große
Abneigung sehen gegen diese Maßnahmen
weil da tatsächlich viel Millionen
Menschen leben die für die Freiheit
gestritten gekämpft haben sich
eingesetzt haben und damit auch etwas
erwirkt haben auch und dass die jetzt
Empfindungen haben zu Recht auch zu
sagen ich will ihn nicht gegängelt
werden in Einrichtungen die ich
vielleicht nicht rein will muss man
absolut nachvollziehen und verstehen
auch aber nochmal die Situation die wir
jetzt haben nicht daran dass die
ungeimpften unsolidarisch sind mit dem
Rest der Gesellschaft den Freiheit ist
zu zitieren auch immer die Freiheit der
anders denken aber und ich muss nicht
das Kollektiv im Blick behalten aber
trotzdem das Gemeinwohl und wenn durch
mein Verhalten viele Menschen
hospitalisiert werden durch mein
ungeimpftes Verhalten und viele Menschen
eben in die Intensivstation müssen im
Endeffekt oder ich selber gar und des
Gesundheitssystem damit belastet da muss
man schon die Frage stellen ist das der
Freiheitsbegriff den wir haben und leben
wollen oder gefährdet dieser
Freiheitsbegriff als totale Ego
Bezogenheit nicht den Rest der
Gemeinschaft ich sehe diesen
preisbegriff eben nicht als das totale
Egon sondern von ihm machen was sie will
uns egal ob jemand schade im Gegenteil
aber die ist es doch na ist es nicht
also worauf ich hinaus will ist dass die
letzte Woche wenn ich so beobachte und
was dazu geschrieben wurde das egal wer
sagt aber denkt auch noch jemanden die
Freiheit also wenn ich sage die Freiheit
muss sie nie rechtfertigen ihre
Beschränkung aber immer und dann kommt
zurück oh Gott das ist dieser dieser
radikal in vidalismus und das geht ja so
nicht also das allein das Aussprechen
dieser einfachen Wahrheit geht schon gar
nicht mehr und man muss das schon
zurückstecken es bestrahlt niemand das
in Pandemien irgendwie Beschränkungen
gelten müssen ich bin geimpft die fragt
meine Maske das ist alles fein ich habe
nicht vor irgendjemanden zu schaden aber
das alleine wenn ich sage können wir
vielleicht drüber nachdenken wie
schwierig das ist eigentlich und dass
das nicht normal ist und dass der
ernsthaft quer durch die deutschen
Medien geschrieben wird hört auf mit
diesem radikal Individualismus der ja
nur Egoismus ist der das finde ich echt
unzählig okay ich muss sagen ich finde
das ganze ist einfach so völlig in in
deutscher Kontinuität und Tradition also
ich finde jetzt keine Spezialität der
corona-politik also dass man jetzt nicht
speziell freiheitsaffin ist in
Deutschland das ist doch irgendwie schon
längstens bekannt also hier ist einfach
genau
absolut nein aber hier ist doch einfach
das große Thema immer Gleichheit und
Gerechtigkeit und da wird darauf
geschaut dass es so ist und und
irgendwie also als ich noch in Berlin
gewohnt habe irgendwie vor vor einem
Jahr dachte ich eigentlich immer die
deutschen könnte man eigentlich zehn
Jahre in den Lockdown schicken und keine
Ahnung würden sich vielleicht ein paar
zählen zählen in Sachsen warum dann aber
die anderen würden zu Hause bleiben das
kann sein aber es ist wirklich schlimmer
geworden als Beispiel ich wurde gestern
auf Twitter sehr hart angegangen dass
meine Aussagen für kovic tote Schuld
werden und da habe ich lange überlegt
das war übrigens von grünen
Bundestagsabgeordneten also jetzt nicht
irgendwie weiß ich habe erst gedacht das
wäre ein Internet Träume sich dann
gesehen habe ach ist ja doch keiner und
ich frage mich wirklich es kommt immer
dieser Begriff Solidarität ich muss
sagen und du weißt ja dass ich geimpft
bin Bela das sage ich ja jetzt auch
immer damit auch bloß keiner denkt ich
wäre jemand der nicht geimpft dass ich
bin geimpft aber wenn ich höre diese
Worte Egoismus die sind schuld da muss
ich sagen und du weißt wie gerne ich
dich mag aber der Regen sich mir so
richtig so da wird mir ganz schlecht bei
mir ich finde Solidarität bedeutet doch
auch solidarisch mit denen zu sein die
gerade vielleicht das Gefühl haben dass
in die Gesellschaft zu viel abverlangt
vielleicht wird irgendwann die
Gesellschaft bei dir in irgendein Punkt
zu viel abverlangen du wir sagen das bin
ich nicht bereit zu geben wie dir jetzt
gerade nicht bereit sind die Impfung
machen zu lassen da müssen wir das
solidarisch stehen und sagen
es ist ja nicht so dass ich das
Grundrecht auf Freiheit ablehne ganz im
Gegenteil nur wie ist die Lage ein
ganzes Volk geht jetzt zum wievielten
zum vierten Mal in Lockdown
wahrscheinlich wir haben die Lage unsere
Wirtschaft leidet die Weihnachtsmärkte
werden abgesagt ich meine das muss
nämlich auch mal vorstellen das sind
Leute die haben Nahrung eingekauft die
haben und und und und und Leute
eingestellt dafür die sind alle jetzt
quasi vor dem wirtschaftsprühen ja und
und flächendecken fast schon bald weil
andere Weihnachtsmärkte neben München
werden sicherlich auch abgesagt werden
also insofern hat es da auch erhebliche
wirtschaftspolitische und
wirtschaftsauswirkungen du bist jemand
der sich sehr für Wirtschaft
interessiert und sich da ausgeht also
das musste man ja nachvollziehen können
auch das heißt
Weihnachtsmärkten doch die ungeimpften
tragen zum Wesentlichen dazu bei dass
das diese Infektionszahlen gibt in zwei
Titel derjenigen die auf den
Intensivstationen liegen sind ungeimpfte
und das sind nicht geimpfte also muss
man doch den Zusammenhang suchen und
weil diese Intensivstationen volllaufen
das ist der Bewertungsmaßstab der neue
deswegen haben wir diesen Lockdown der
bald kommt und deswegen haben wir diese
verschärfenen Maß aber es geht doch auch
um strategisches Verhalten der Politik
will man die Bürger für die Politik
gewinnen oder nicht wenn man sie nicht
gewinnen will sagt man ihnen Vollidioten
oder irgendwie bekloppte und das hat man
eben schon sehr früh auf angefangen
hatte ich den Eindruck in Deutschland
man hat die Leute eben schon vermutlich
viel zu früh aufgegeben und jetzt ist es
tatsächlich vermutlich zu spät man muss
vielleicht auch mal sagen freiheit ist
das Recht aus der Reihe tanzen zu dürfen
und wenn über 70% geimpft sind dann ist
das für eine freiheitliche Ordnung egal
in welchem Kontext ein riesen Mehrheit
das gibt es bei keinen Wahlen das gibt
es bei den wenigsten Volksabstimmungen
dass eine Nation so geschlossen zu mehr
als zwei Dritteln hinter einem Thema
steht wenn man jetzt sozusagen
koreanische Mehrheitsverhältnisse weil
die Lage es gerade erfordert einfordert
dann überfordert man einfach unser
Grundsystem
so sind wir nicht gestrickt wenn man
sagt alle sollen sich impfen lassen es
mit Nordkorea gleich zu setzen das ist
natürlich
was wäre die Lösung also
bin ich felsenfest von überzeugt sie
wird es geben aufgrund der Tatsache dass
viele sagen ich lass mich nicht impfen
nicht bereit dazu sind und wie diese
Zustände haben wie wir sie haben und ich
will nicht noch eine fünfte Welle haben
ich glaube dass er dass der Blick ein
falscher ist zu sagen dass die
ungeimpften also eine wirklich kleine
Gruppe dass die Schuld an an dem Ganzen
sind wir haben aus dem außer Acht
gelassen dass auch geimpfte weitertragen
wir haben außer Acht gelassen dass
Kinder beispielsweise auch dem das Virus
tragen und verbreiten können und das
trifft dann welche also das das
geschehen ist aus meiner Sicht komplexer
als dass man sich jetzt auf eine doch
sehr kleine gesellschaftliche Gruppe
einstellen